einer sagt lasst doch die
landesregierung die sollen doch jetzt
den menschen den eltern den schülern und
schülerinnen sagen nach den sommerferien
gibt es auf jeden fall wieder normalen
präsenzunterricht und der der das sagt
ist friedrich merz schönen guten abend
herr merz unter weise
sie fordern die landesregierung auf den
eltern beziehungsweise schülern und
schülerinnen zu sagen dass abgesehen von
ausnahmen jetzt wieder schulunterricht
auf jeden fall stattfinden wird nach den
sommerferien was spricht denn dagegen
das so einfach klar umzusetzen ab sofort
also warum wird das nicht einfach
gemacht weil sie ich finde wir brauchen
jetzt wirklich einmal ein
perspektivwechsel und müssen uns das
ganze geschehen einmal aus der sicht der
kinder der jugendlichen auch der
studentinnen und der studenten anschauen
jüngsten in unserer gesellschaft und die
junge generation haben wirklich ganz
schwierige 18 monate hinter sich und ich
finde sie haben jetzt anspruch darauf
klarheit zu bekommen was ab september
los ist wie das mit den schulen mit dem
kindergärten und mit den universitäten
wieder weitergeht und wir haben noch
etwas zeit bis zum ende der sommerferien
auch alles darauf vorzubereiten dass das
wirklich gut funktioniert aber diese
zeit sollte jetzt genutzt werden und
deswegen habe ich das so gesagt jetzt
klarheit zu verschaffen und wie gesagt
aus der perspektive der kinder der
jugendlichen zu sagen
der schulunterricht die kindergärten er
unterricht an den universitäten in
präsenz findet ab dem herbst wirklich
definitiv wieder statt und alles was
danach vornehmlich ist drum herum wird
gemacht also perspektivwechsel
wir müssen uns noch einmal die welt
anschauen aus dem blick derer die unter
der pandemie am meisten blut das würde
absolut zeit nur das gegenteil passiert
im moment noch gerade ich habe gerade
die tage per e mail für unsere schule zu
hause noch ein brief bekommen kein
mensch weiß wie es nach den sommerferien
weitergeht wir sind relativ frühen die
sommerferien gestartet in berlin
da steht drin ist könnte auch wieder
sein dass im herbst wechsel unterricht
kommt also der herrscht die totale
unsicherheit und weiterhin auch
verunsicherung was spricht also dagegen
das einfach umzusetzen jetzt die schule
garantie beispielsweise angefangen bei
ihnen den westfalen mit
auch schwarzen landesregierung die
landesregierung nordrhein-westfalen hat
ja am letzten freitag bereits
weitgehende lockerung in kraft gesetzt
in nordrhein-westfalen ich es richtig
beurteilen sind wir am weitesten damit
und ich habe dem ministerpräsidenten
haben die laschet auch am wochenende
darüber gesprochen wir sind uns einig
darüber dass das weitergehen muss dass
das pandemie geschehen natürlich im
blick behalten werden muss dass wir
nicht leichtsinnig werden dürfen
aber wir sind uns auch einig darüber
dass es eine ganz klare perspektive
geben muss jedenfalls in nordrhein
westfalen berlin kann ich nicht
beurteilen scheint etwas komplizierter
dort zu sein aber in nordrhein-westfalen
im größten bundesland der bundesrepublik
deutschland in dem ich ja auch selbst
lebe muss klarheit bestehen und ich habe
den eindruck die landesregierung in
nordrhein westfalen will das auch
arbeiten jetzt nur um diese schule
garantie weil das ist ja was die ihren
vorschlag sofort aufgenommen das würde
millionen eltern millionen kindern aus
dem herzen sprechen im moment in
deutschland also wie kriegen wir das
schnell hin die nächste
kultusministerkonferenz die dauert noch
die wird erst in monaten stattfinden
also wie kommen wir jetzt dahin ihren
vorschlag umzusetzen wer muss das machen
die verantwortung dafür liegt bei den
ländern nicht bei der
kultusministerkonferenz oder bei der
bundesregierung sondern sie liegt
eindeutig bei den ländern die länder
sind verantwortlich für die schulen die
kindergärten auch für die universitäten
und deswegen können die länder die sie
in eigener zuständigkeit jetzt auch
sagen und noch einmal ich finde es ist
jetzt wirklich an der zeit dass wir uns
unabhängig davon wie alt wir selber sind
einmal die welt anschauen aus den augen
der kinder der jugendlichen der
studenten und studentinnen und wenn wir
das richtig machen dann können wir
glaube ich und dieser perspektive
aussagen also es fängt jetzt die da an
es geht der präsenzunterricht wieder los
und alles was dafür erforderlich ist sei
ist reinigungsgeräte in den
unterrichtsräumen sei es masken die man
vielleicht auch auf zeit noch tragen
muss vielleicht auch die näherinnen und
deren zu sagen wir erwarten dass ihre
dienste
wenn die schule wieder beginnt das sind
vorbereitungsarbeiten die jetzt in den
sommerferien geleistet werden können
wissen sie ja weise ich möchte vermeiden
dass wir im herbst und dann sind wir
mitten in der bundestagswahl über diese
themen auf dem rücken der kinder einen
politischen streit austragen muss
und deswegen ist jetzt die zeit gekommen
die vorbereitungsarbeiten zu lassen da
laufen wir natürlich längst rein also
wir haben jetzt eben nur noch ein paar
wochen je nach bundesland sommerferien
und es reicht eben nicht mehr den
lehrern jetzt zu sagen sie sollen sich
impfen lassen das wissen die ja schon
lange
wer es bisher nicht gemacht hat dass es
hat ja jeder lehrer jede lehrerin eben
für angebot mittlerweile bekommen der
will das ja offenbar nicht ist das nicht
nur unverschämtheit eigentlich gegenüber
den schülerinnen und schülerinnen wenn
man sich als lehrer nicht impfen lässt
und dann möglicherweise noch monate lang
sich selbst schützt damit zu hause
bleiben möchte und damit eben
weiterbildung verhindert lehrerinnen und
lehrer auch universitätsprofessorinnen
und professoren haben in deutschland
eine besondere verantwortung auch
diejenigen die in den kindergärten sind
ich finde man kann von dieser gruppe
schon ein sehr verantwortungsvolles
verhalten warten ich respektiere wenn
ich es auch nicht selber nachvollziehen
kann aber ich respektiere diejenigen die
aus gründen die ich nur begrenzt
verstehe aber immerhin es gibt sie sich
grundsätzlich nicht impfen lassen wollen
aber das kann eigentlich kein argument
sein noch einmal diese personengruppe
steht in ganz besonderen verantwortung
diese personen bekommen etwas in die
hand was das wertvollste gesellschaft
ist nämlich unsere kinder
von daher muss man noch einmal an ihre
verantwortung appellieren und jetzt sind
es noch vier wochen fünf wochen sechs
wochen in einigen länger im stoff ist in
randen also bitte die erwartung sollte
klar und deutlich formuliert werden an
diejenigen verantwortung
jetzt ist es ihnen herr merz so ergangen
wie ganz vielen in den letzten monaten
die für schul öffnungen eingetreten sind
in der politik oder schule öffnungen
gefordert haben sie sind beschimpft
worden auch von karl lauterbach
beispielsweise der gesprochen hat von
einem feldversuch von einem gefährlichen
feldversuch den man da nicht wagen
sollte das heißt er hat gesagt sie
fordern etwas was den kindern schaden
würde wie entgegnen sie solcher kritik
naja also eher lauterbach hat ja nun
seinerseits eine ganze reihe von kritik
und widerspruch bekommen auch aus der
fachwelt
tallis aus der sich eher jungen
generation und wenn man die letzten 18
monate einmal revue passieren lässt das
ist die gruppe die von infektionen wenn
sie denn stattgefunden haben am
allerwenigsten mit schwerem verlauf
betroffen sein
und das ist gleichzeitig die gruppe die
durch die einschränkungen in den schulen
universitäten kindertagesstätten
kindergärten am meisten betroffen war
von den einschränkungen und das ist die
gruppe die das alles zurückzahlen muss
was jetzt an corona hilfen in milliarden
höhe gezahlt worden
also ich finde wir können jetzt einmal
wirklich die position dieser generation
einnehmen und mal sagen ihr seid nicht
wirklich ernsthaft gefährdet durch das
virus schützen euch so gut wir können
aber wir geben euch noch die chance im
september nach den sommerferien zum
regelunterricht zurückzukehren wie
übernehmen dafür politisch die
verantwortung und wir tun alles was
möglich ist um euch zu schützen bis hin
für die älteren schülerinnen und schüler
studentinnen und studenten ohnehin auch
ein info mache nicht das was gang
schäuble am wochenende gesagt hat ja man
kann auch kinder ab zwölf jahre wie ich
sie in der verantwortungsvollsten ich
würde es jedenfalls mit meinen kindern
tun empfehle ich meinen kindern auch für
unsere enkel endlich der
perspektivwechsel endlich aus den augen
der kinder auf diese krise schauen da
bin ich total bei ihnen herr merz aber
es passiert ja in den öffentlichen
diskurs weit gehen noch was ganz anderes
sie werden beschimpft
armin laschet wird bestimmtes läuft
übers wochenende eine twitter welle
durchs land die lasche welle davon ist
die rede herren laschet wird wegen der
lockerungen aktuelle in
nordrhein-westfalen vorgeworfen
menschenleben zu riskieren ganz konkret
und das auch aus dem mund von grünen
politikern beispielsweise erich marx war
der grüne europaabgeordnete der sagt er
vergleicht das mit dem was sie gesagt
haben mit dem auto fahren ohne
sicherheitsgurt also wo stehen wir da
aktuell in der
lockdown corona debatte also wir stehen
offensichtlich in einer sich
verschärfenden auseinandersetzung die
jetzt auch persönlich wird ich bedauere
das sehr ich respektiere andere
meinungen aber ich teile sie und wenn
ich sie nicht teile dann fange ich nicht
an meine politischen gegner so
persönlich herabsetzende zu beschimpfen
wie das in einzelnen fällen in den
letzten tagen zu beobachten war
das ist nicht anständig was da passiert
wir alle sind darum bemüht dieses
problem gemeinsam so schnell wie möglich
zu lösen und wenn es dann entscheidungen
wie die landesregierung von nordrhein
westfalen gibt wenn es denn meinungen
gibt wie die von armin laschet und auch
von mir dann haben wir glaube ich
anspruch darauf dass dies respektiert
wird das damit anständig umgegangen wird
und dass das nicht in dieser
unerträglichen unflätigen art und weise
diskreditiert wird nur wie wir das
leider insbesondere aus den reihen der
grünen den letzten tagen gehört ist ein
klarer worte von friedrich merz eine
frage zu einer aktuellen studie über die
bild morgen groß berichten wird vom
robert koch institut und die ist
deswegen so interessant hier geht es um
indikatoren für den herbst und winter 20
21 22 also für die nächsten monate und
da schreibt das robert koch-institut
weitgehende nicht pharmakologische
interventionen für alle für alle also
vor allen dingen für die geimpften sein
im herbst fachlich schwer begründbar
man komme in eine endemische situation
mit saisonalen epidemien also raus aus
der pandemie und deswegen seien solche
scharfen corona regeln für alle eben
nicht mehr begründbar ist das hier ist
dass das was wir gerade erleben als
wende in der korona politik eben ein
weggehen von den ja incidents werten ein
mehr drauf schauen auf hospitalisierung
auf das was wirklich in den
krankenhäusern abgeht und vor allen
dingen dahingehend mehr rechte für alle
rechte zurück für diejenigen die geimpft
sind
er weiß ich habe das schon vor einem
jahr gesagt die einschränkung von
grundrechten ist immer nur in besonderen
situationen zulässig die kollektive der
kollektive entzug von grundrechten für
die gesamte bevölkerung nur weil es
einige teile der bevölkerung gibt
gefährdet sind die pandemie lässt sich
nicht
erhalten und deswegen sind wir
wahrscheinlich genau auf dem weg in das
robert-koch-institut jetzt beschrieben
hat ich habe von dieser studie gelesen
teile die einschätzung und ich bitte
auch darum dass alle die die anderer
meinung sind und noch einmal ich
respektiere andere meinung teile sie
nicht aber ich respektiere sie dass alle
jetzt wirklich zu einer anständigen
diskussion zusammenfinden und wir aus
der situation in der wir sind und die
insbesondere für die kinder und
jugendlichen wirklich richtig schwer ist
und ihre familie darunter sehr gelitten
dass wir für alle offen sind jetzt das
beste machen und uns auf einen guten
herbst vorbereiten dass dieses thema
wenn eben möglich aus der
parteipolitischen auseinandersetzung
heraus bleibt ist das eine wende in der
korona politik kann man so weit gehen
davon zu sprechen
es könnte eine wende sein wie alle
hoffen es eine gewissheit hat niemand
von uns aber ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass es in der tat diese lang ersehnte
erhoffte wende für uns alle ist
danke für das gespräch friedrich merz